Chris Mannix from Yahoo Sports covering
the NBA there in Cleveland last night
and courtside to that injury with Gordon
Hayward what did you see on that play
Chris well I mean Dan it was it was
really as significant severe and
injuries I've ever seen in person you
know up until that point there was a lot
of energy in the building I mean Kyrie
Irving I was getting booed for
introductions every time he touched the
ball there was a feeling there towards
Irving at that moment I mean everyone
just completely you know altered their
perspective there is it's hard to put
into words what it was that looked at it
then and for a while I wasn't sure what
I was looking at it's almost like my
eyes were deceiving me and then they
take a couple of minutes to look back
and it just was where's just protests to
look at all right let's look at this now
as we move forward the Celtics have
their home opener tonight against
Milwaukee but handicap the Eastern
Conference now well I mean you gotta put
Cleveland the pole position at the
moment good and obvious to see what
happens when when they figure out what's
what's going on with Hayward I mean I I
was told by some some team officials
last night that were involved in in
looking at Hayward that it you know they
say he may have avoided something
catastrophic and you know they were
optimistic that there might be a
possibility he could return at some
point this season as crazy as it sounds
I'm not banking on that but even if he
was able to come back a lot Paul George
from a couple of years ago you can't
expect it to be anywhere near 100% but
putting that aside I think Cleveland is
number one and I look at Washington
right now as number two I mean the
wizard had a very good preseason in
terms of what their starters were able
to do I think their bench will be better
because you'll see what one or more of
their starters on that second unit more
consistently which was their problem
last year I like Washington - and then
you're looking at Boston Toronto may be
fighting for that third and fourth but I
don't think Boston could fall any
further than fourth I like their young
players Jalen Brown is really good Jason
Tatum is going to be really good I think
midseason and beyond an Eastern
Conference's just god-awful so I think
Boston still slides that top four or
five in the at the end of the season
third best team in the NBA is who third
best team right now right now I'd
probably say San Antonio I am concerned
with with Kawhi Leonard's quad injury
and the fact that we're not getting any
kind of timetable on his return and the
fact that it's not a it's not his first
quad injury in that area but if they're
healthy in the first few weeks month of
the season the working they have going
for them dan is continuity and that's
important to get it early don't start
the season the Rockets warm last night
and they should take a lot of pride in
going to Golden State and getting a win
but they're gonna have some bumps and
bruises along the way I mean
incorporating all those new guys
incorporating Chris Paul that's good
that's gonna be a challenge with that
team but the Spurs at least can compact
on the same rotation the same unit that
they've had moving forward so I think
right now without knowing how the
Rockets and the Thunder come together I
would say San Antonio's f3 he's Chris
Mannix from Yahoo Sports NBA analyst NBA
writer give me the best case scenario
for the Lakers they are so bad that they
get to keep their pick if it lands at
number one and maybe they're not as bad
as we think and they wind up at six
seven or eight and they also keep their
pick I mean really you're only looking
at the draft pick now but if it falls
between 2 & 5 Boston gets it so the
Lakers right now are sitting kind of in
that sweet spot they're probably the
third or fourth worst team in the NBA
I mean maybe because the East has this
this incredible race for the body I've
never seen I mean you know you saw that
fight between like Bobby Portis and and
his teammate in that mirror too you know
Meritage like you almost wonder like
half-heartedly like did the Bulls plan
this to like lose a couple more guys so
they could be even worse this year and
get it even higher drastic at the end of
the year I mean the pool the Knicks to
the Mets to the magic I mean on down the
list the Eastern Conference
so maybe if the Lakers as they're trying
to win they can be super sixth worst but
but it's not gonna be pretty I mean
every is excited about Lonzo okay but
they're gonna lose a ton of games could
the Lakers make the playoffs in the
Eastern Conference considering it is
hilarious you know I mean look I
honestly believed in there's gonna be a
47 or 48 win team that doesn't get into
playoffs on the west
maybe it's Denver maybe somebody else as
long same lines there might be a 35 win
team that gets in the East I mean in the
Indiana sitting there with the
possibility of sneaking into the
playoffs at 35 wins
it's and look it's not gonna get much
better above a 337 at the 70 40 at the
six seed it truly is as bad as I've seen
the eastern comput saw I will say no
that the Lakers couldn't make the glass
knees but they beginning in marks put it
that way
JoEllen bead said the Sixers have to
listen to him about restricting his
minutes he said it's it's bleeping bull
bleep I wish I was playing more minutes
I think I'm ready I think I'm ready for
more whatever numbers they have I don't
know I wish I was playing more but we're
going to have to see how that goes
what should the philosophy be with Joe
LM beat in Philadelphia right I mean Joe
Allen B needs to calm down a little bit
he's played 31 games his career in three
seasons he's coming off a knee injury
that was was far more significant than
the people originally thought I mean he
had what I believe was hard the stopper
surgery for the end of the season and
and he was gonna film the effects I into
training camp and what the fixative
saved him 150 million dollars like that
that's they're not going to screw around
with that I mean look Philadelphia is
probably a playoff team this year again
because the East is so bad but you know
their game plan is long-term they're you
know year three year for Ben Simmons OLM
beat Dario Sark and hopefully Markel
folks playing alongside each other
they're gonna go months with joylynn
beat on a very significant I think a
minutes restriction or at least it
should be until he proves that he is
100% healthy Chris thanks for joining
we appreciate your time know that you've
been traveling thanks for joining us hi
Chris Mannix covers the NBA for Yahoo
Sports the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you